the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon update video in this
video i will be discussing lane or
velaryon and his dragon sea smoke the
reason why i'm making this video is
because i noticed something after house
of the dragon's third episode ended
shortly after the new episode ended on
sunday night i noticed there were a lot
of fans unsure of what actually happened
in the final scene during the battle
against the crab feeder's men during
that battle we see lenore velaryon and
his dragon sea smoke deliver air strikes
on the enemy soldiers down below there
were a lot of fans on facebook asking
who the dragon was as well as who was
the man riding on its back i actually
saw many fans asking if that was daemon
on someone else's dragon or if that was
someone else on daemon's dragon karaxis
i even saw some fans asking if that was
bastion from the neverending story well
as i've already said that was lanor
velaryon the son of lord coreless
velaryon and rhaenys targaryen his mount
sea smoke is a silvery gray dragon who
is obviously a fighting size during the
dance of the dragons now although sea
smoke is a young dragon he is
considerably more nimble in the air than
his older brothers you have to remember
there will be 17 dragons in this show
and we will see 9 of them in the first
season alone you will be seeing a lot
more dragons and their writers in the
following episodes if you want to know
who all of the dragons are as well as
their writers i would suggest watching
my video i released right before the
season started in that video i go over
every living dragon and i reveal who is
riding on them during the dance of the
dragons when the real battles actually
begin
now another thing i noticed fans were
wondering is how was laenor valerion
able to fly on this dragon well you have
to remember his mother is rhaenys
targaryen who is a dragon rider herself
if you remember in game of thrones jon
snow wrote a dragon as well although
only his father was actually a targaryen
lenore is as much a targaryen as jon
snow was the only real difference are
their features jon snow obviously favors
his mother which is why he had the dark
hair whereas lenore's father and mother
both have the white blonde hair making
him look like a super targaryen you will
be seeing a lot more half targaryens in
this show riding on dragons now i want
to show you how different the dragons
actually look because i know there were
some fans who thought this was daemon's
dragon karaxis one thing some of you
might not know is house of the dragon
showrunner said there would be three
different dragon breeds in the show and
i think all three of these dragons i'm
about to mention are from a different
breed because of their distinct features
now if you look at daemon's dragon
karaxis you can see it has the shape of
a snake or even a worm
in fact karaxis is also known as the
blood worm which is a very fitting name
not only is he red like blood but he's
also shaped like a damn worm with his
long ass body and neck for me he stands
out from the other dragons the most
that's what i love about karaxis so much
no other dragon looks like him so far
now if you look at raniere's dragon
psyrax it looks a lot more like a
dinosaur to me it does have somewhat of
a long neck but nowhere near as long as
karaxis raniere's dragon cyrax has the
head and face that reminds me of a
velociraptor now leonor valerion's
dragon sea smoke looks a lot more like
dany's dragons if you ask me his dragon
has the face head and belly of a drogon
rhaegal or vasarion so as you can see
daemon's dragon is shaped more like a
snake or a worm ronira's dragon is short
and shaped a lot like a flying dinosaur
and lenore's dragon sea smoke looks a
lot like dany's dragons from game of
thrones hopefully this video did help
some of you out i just wanted to make a
short video because i know there were
some fans feeling lost after the new
episode ended let me know what you think
down below or if there is any more
information you want to add leave that
down below as well as always i want to
thank all of you for stopping by and
watching the video i hope all of you
have a great day i will see you again
very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you